good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs are
going to solve all of the world's major
problems so to help you on your journey
today's message is find a balance in
your life over to you Jetley
[Music]
Rene what rzc he'd be below me email me
if I'm entry to the casa minha crikey
Kalkaji gave of mission without a year
Iran says oh you're the hydrophobic so
Lisa Monaco keychain Thomas oh taeho
pseudo show ho
voila whooping and about some cotton the
Bellagio the Congo yen vinyasa yoga Josh
Cindy artificial situation accommodation
congenial minions Arianna vision see a
motion for a vote Elly parents mention
sue descended to delegate origami
question she's research if a man were to
determine identity would have written
gamma the cheering chemical the chisel
Quattro sustain vida to taniyama-shimura
union dues are paid him nearer his
vegetables over five atados action
my Kanagawa legal team questo magnifique
or should we not do now
I think balance is really important but
I think it looks different for different
people I think you need to understand
what is balance for you as an example I
remember listening to an audio series by
Tony Robbins and I love Tony Robbins and
he was going through right down your
list of goals and talked about you know
if you want to be a painter write down I
want to make this painting or I want to
write this masterpiece or I want to
create this poem or make this sculpture
and because he was so excited into it
like yeah I want to make a painting I
want to make a masterpiece I want to
create a sculpture and it started
building up my list of things that I
wanted to do kind of outside of just the
business world and then when I looked at
it I realized I don't actually really
want to do those things
and I got kind of externally motivated
by Tony in that moment but it's not
really what balance means to me and so I
think it's super important not to just
look at somebody else's life but to do a
regular audit I think one of the most
important things that you can do as a
human being is do a quarterly audit of
your life and see where are you spending
your time and does it match to the goals
that you're trying to accomplish so if
you're feeling like you're working too
hard
then what are the other kitties that
you're doing how much time are you
spending and doing that quarterly audit
because your life will always change and
your goals and your priorities will
change my schedule changes at least once
a month but in a major way probably once
a quarter where I need to adjust my
priorities based on how I'm evolving as
human being some things I just don't
care about any more I'm still spending
time on I need to eliminate those some
things I need to spend more time on them
I'm drawn towards and so I need to
factor that in and put it in my calendar
I can tell what your priorities are by
looking at your calendar and so if
there's something that you think is
really important if you're trying to
find more balance if you're trying to
work harder you want to make sure these
priorities get done schedule it into
your calendar both the personal things
and the business things and stick to it
if you do that then you'll be able to
build the life that you
so the question a today is I'm curious
what does balance look like for you
leave it down the comments below super
curious to find out I also want to give
a quick shout out to these Martinez
these thank you so much for picking up a
copy of my book your one word it really
really really means a lot to me and I
hope you're enjoying the read so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I will see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events
[Music]
it's complex right and it's deceiving at
times you know because people think
you're to equate yes you know to each
other and they don't right you have a
lot of money it's up here and I have a
lot of happiness but that doesn't mean
that the to equate to each other as your
happiness result the same amount of your
bank account no that's the thing they
don't they don't they don't equate or
they're not as hide in any way that tied
to each other I mean it allows you
freedom and allows you to go places
where you could smile and look at the
sunset and things like that that's what
you choose to do you enjoy the
difference but there are a lot of people
with tons of money who aren't happy
because they're either they've become a
prison of their money or they've become
so consumed with getting money that they
don't allow time for happiness right
life is about balance right you have to
have some type of balance you have like
time for work and it's time for play and
if you don't allow these two things to
code this you have an imbalance of one
it up I got great advice from you know
one of the people that totally
fascinates me is Bob Iger he's the CEO
of the Walt Disney ABC world and he so
his job is so weird to me because he is
in charge of everything from like a
Disney cruise to George Stephanopoulos
ABC News like he that he had to like a
theme park to scandal like every all of
that falls into the ABC Disney family
and I asked him and it was very helpful
to me I asked him a few months ago like
how do you decide what you're going to
work on in a day and he said something
so valuable to me so I want to share
with you guys he said 80% of his time he
tries to think about where can I have
impact where am I going to make a
difference in the day today so it may
not usually be Disney cruises but
sometimes it needs to be because the
cruise business has been doing what the
cruise business is doing or that's not
quoting him by the way but there you
know it may sometimes it's a Broadway
show that's about to open sometimes it's
they eat the ESPYs because ESPN that's
where his focus needs to be so it's
really about like where can I have
impact today and the other where am I
needed the other 20% is what brings me
joy you know so there are certain movie
projects
that fall under the ABC disney world
that bring him joy or certain shows are
certain you know an opening of a park or
there are certain things that bring him
that just fill him up that fall in his
work responsibilities and I just really
try have tried to bring that with me
because you know it's important for us
to remember the joy in what we do it's
important to be effective in our
workplace but it's important to
cultivate the moments that just bring us
joy because that's how we'll shine in
our in our lives as professionals you
know how do you balance so much how do
you balance having successful career and
maintaining your socializes your family
all of it it's a different kind of
enjoying yourself when you get older as
a young girl before I got married I
owned property
I had car I lived a luxurious life in
fabulous like I was a bachelor rich yep
my dance card was fall I had boyfriend I
had a life but a career not going to
keep you warm at night and money is not
the answer
happiness you know you create this
peaceful balance of everything at least
that's what I think if you ask Wendy
yeah that's what I say and I only know
that because of separate lives life